الان المجتمعات العربيه تمر بحاله نوعيه
من التغيرات والتطورات في بنيتها
المجتمعيه والمجتمع السعودي في اولى او
طليعه هذه المجتمعات الان الدراسات التي
تجري لدراسه هذه التغيرات وهذه التنوعات
اما دراسه في علم الاجتماع او علم التاريخ
او علم السياسه في هذه المرحله وفي وضوء
خطط
استراتيجيه التنميه المستدامه لرؤيه عشرين
ثلاثين العلم القادر من وجهه نظري على
دراسه هذه الظواهر في التغير وفي التطور
الحضاري السعودي هو علم الانتروبولوجيا
السعوديه
كونه يمتاز بسمتين السمه الاولى هو يستطيع
ان يدرس المجتمع السعودي في مراحله الاولى
ومرحلته الان او المرحله الراهنه ويجري
دراسه مقارنه ما بين الماضي والحاضر اضافه
الى ان يستعين بمنهج الانتروبولوج تطبيقيه
لتطبيق النتائج العلميه التي توصلت اليها
الانتروبولوجيا السعوديه في دراسه المجتمع
السعودي خلال فترات زمنيه محدده واماكن
جغرافيه محدده مع مقارنتها بمنجزات الحاضر
بهدف بناء نظريه علميه لبناء مستقبل زاهر
فيما يتعلق بالتطور التنموي السعودي وهذا
تعتقد غير لم نتوصل
ما يقول اخواننا المصريين بعافيه حبتين
حتى يعني علم الانتروبولوجيا الى الان لا
يدرس في الجامعه السعوديه في معرفته يعني